[Music]
[Applause]
i
love wearing wine and we need a little
sparkle
i wanted something a little classic a
little sexy
is it true that coffee just got her
first valentino
valentino was kind enough to send us
mommy and daughter matching bags
so for everyone who thought i bought my
child a
3 000 plus dollar bag when she can't
poop in the potty
on her own
pink in all pink brought her kids willa
rocked furry leopard print slippers and
jamison did cowboy boots for the celeb
filled black carpet
oh the back the back
so there's detail detail detail lots of
sparkles and
just lots of detail gabby stunned in
this tiered gold gown her husband cade
was in charge of that
giant train he's been walking with this
dress all night making sure you didn't
fall that's a gentleman
he's a sweetie alicia keys also had a
handler for her
massive cape but she changed out of the
pink three-piece valentino number to
perform in
all denim oh excuse me do you want to
like sparkle a little bit what's that
one
i've been in pajamas a year beyonce's
mama went glam in a moschino pant suit
while priyanka chopra channeled queen
bay in dolce and gabbana beyonce rocked
a similar metal belt back in 2007 as for
nick walking to the red carpet
he wasn't the only star going green
megan fox gets our award for most talked
about look
her black mugler bodysuit didn't leave a
lot to the imagination
dojicat gave us beetlejuice vibes in
balman and
get this her earrings were alive those
are real
venus flytraps
kelsey ballerini was over the moon and
star struck after a drake sighting
and found a creative way to handle a
fashion emergency
i get a little nervous and my feet get
sweaty so i found a good solution